[Music]  we need  cop the world needs him  she's the only one he'll communicate  with  [Music]  it's godzilla  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  godzilla vs kong in theaters and  streaming exclusively on hbo max march  31st rated pg-13  this is our only chance  we have to take it  [Music]  we need kong the world needs him  to stop what's coming  and this child she's the only one he'll  communicate with  i knew that they had a bond she had  nowhere to go  so i made a promise to protect her  and i think that in some way khan did  the same  [Music]  it's godzilla  [Music]  here we go  these are dangerous times godzilla's out  there and he's hurting people and we  don't know why  there's something provoking him that  we're not seeing  [Music]  and they're the last ones standing for  greatness because  no one  [Music]  you